[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
débat consacré ce soir au fameux
compteurs linky
vous en avez peut-être déjà un chip vous
ce compteur intelligent doit remplacer
d'ici à 2021 tous les anciens compteurs
électriques selon aînés 10 la filiale
d'edf en charge de son déploiement
il doit permettre de mieux gérer notre
consommation d'électricité et faciliter
la transition énergétique
mais certains élus refuse d'installer le
boîtier innovant
ils dénoncent des factures plus élevé un
risque pour la santé
et s'inquiète de l'utilisation finale
des données nous avons souhaité lui
consacrer cette émission pour y voir
plus clair avec nous pour en parler
bertrand guillon vous êtes maire de
magny les hameaux
anne-marie goussard vous êtes membre de
l'équipe nationale inc qui chez aînés 10
et philippe le ray vous êtes président
de l'ufc que choisir de versailles
bonsoir à tous les trois d'abord
j'aimerais qu'on comprenne bien pourquoi
il fallait changer de counter al marri
goussard expliquez nous alors c'est très
simple au fait on change de compteurs à
peu près tous les 25 30 ans et à chaque
fois on essaie de trouver la meilleure
technique disponible par rapport aux
nouveaux besoins
quelque chose a fondamentalement changé
dans le paysage énergétique français
c'est l'émergence énergies renouvelables
hier la transition énergétique jusqu'à
maintenant l'électricité allaient
directement des grandes centrales de
production qu'elle soit thermique
hydraulique nucléaire vers le client
final
aujourd'hui elles arrivent de partout il
ya 370 mille producteurs d'énergie
renouvelable de salir les gens comme
vous et moi qui produisent leurs propres
électriques et/ou un panneaux sur leurs
toits
il y en a plus de 2000 dans le
département des yvelines et ils
produisent à de manière intermittente
territoire c'est dire qu'il ya du soleil
et bien ça produit 100 %
et puis un nuage on passe directement à
0 et ça il faut le gérer parce que la
qualité de votre électricité le fait que
la lumière soit toujours au même niveau
ça vient de l' équilibre permanent entre
la consommation et la production
et si elle baisse de production ou s'il
ya une augmentation de la production ça
peut créer des surtensions sont tous
sous tension nous sommes obligés d'avoir
des capteurs pour équilibrer un peu
man ans et puis il ya des tas de
nouveaux usages le véhicule électrique
je suis venu en véhicule électrique on
peut le recharger n'importe où à
n'importe quel endroit au bureau la nuit
chez soi au centre commercial etc
donc nous fallait un outil pour ça il
nous fait là nouveaux compteurs pour de
nouveaux usages
voilà voyage était déjà de voiliers nous
faut nous fallait aussi on est en 2017
et nous n'avons aucune visibilité sur le
réseau basse tension
s'il ya une panne chez vous il faut
qu'on attend que vous nous téléphoniez
en 2010 est donc d'autres jeunes comme
ça va vous permettre à noter un
adversaire là dessus bertrand guillon
vous êtes donc le maire de magny les
hameaux vous avez refusé d'installer
d'installer par dans ce conteur quel est
votre principal reproche on a plusieurs
inquiétudes qui font que nous avons pris
cette délibération fin mars
première inquiétude risques sanitaires
aujourd'hui il y à des fortes
interrogations de la part de la
population par rapport à tout ce qui
concerne les ondes avec de l'électro
sensibilité qui qui apparaît et qui dont
on parle de plus en plus souvent mais
pour laquelle
les normes aujourd'hui sont pas
forcément adaptées en tout cas il ya
énormément d'inquiétudes de la part de
la population ensuite ce qu'il faut
c'est 6 et le compteur est communicant
c'est à dire qu'ils envoient des données
il en reçoit raison voilà ici et c'est
par les ondes par exemple dans le
courant porteur en ligne yappa dons ont
presque dix ans je t'écris après excusez
moi pour la ensuite deuxième élément
c'est les données personnelles et il y a
aujourd'hui des inquiétudes sur
l'utilisation possible des données
personnelles qu'il y a
en transmission ensuite autre
interrogation c'est le coût à l'usagé
comment comment est financée
ce déploiement aujourd'hui puisque on a
plusieurs millions de compteurs est-ce
que c'est dans le cadre des impôts est
ce que c'est dans le cadre d dans le
cadre des des contrats de chaque client
il y a toujours cette cette
interrogation
ce qui nous a poussé aujourd'hui à faire
cette délibération c'est que on a posé
des questions on a d'abord interpellé
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui est délégataire pour la
commune de magny les hameaux qui nous a
répondu à une chèvre mi chou et et qui
n'a finalement pas trop répondu on a
interrogé les dix on a demandé qu'il y
ait une réunion publique qui se passe à
magny les hameaux
la télé lieu elle n'a pas eu lieu il
nous a été répondu à ce moment là que ça
n'était pas nécessaire et ça ne se
faisait pas on va s'arranger et du coup
à un moment il faut aussi faire bouger
les choses
c'est le rôle de cette délibération
maintenant ce que je regrette c'est que
cette délibération directement on peut
se dire celle usa juridique
c'est un peu bizarre pour engager des
discussions directement cette
délibération est attaqué à la fois par
l'état
et puis à la fois par l église donc j'ai
deux recours gracieux vous n'êtes pas le
seul un flux précisé lors de plusieurs
communes je crois une centaine si je ne
me trompe
ce sont donc dresser contre ce compteur
pour terminer le tour de table philippe
le ray de votre côté côté consommateurs
désirent inquiétudes de votre alors de
notre côté bon nous avons toujours été
favorable à ce que les consommateurs
bénéficient des progrès technologiques
bien évidemment toutefois il ya toujours
une prudence parce que lorsqu'il ya des
évolutions comme ça dans l'offre ou aux
consommateurs il ya toujours parfois des
risques ou des offres services qui sont
pas complètement finalisé ou bien donc
on est toujours très vigilante façon à
ce que des changements de technologie ne
se fasse pas au détriment des
consommateurs
ou bien qui ne privilégie pas uniquement
la partie offre donc il ya un équilibre
entre les deux partis qu'ils soient
réalisés et que donc les risques par
exemple au temps partiel mer soit bien
examiner et qu'on ait des assurances et
des garanties de ce côté là vous avez
fait un dossier là dessus un sommet
absolu ce matin donc du côté de la
consommation votre conclusion c'est du
côté du coup pardon alors du côté du
côté du du coup ce que le ce que l'on
sait si vous voulez c'est que bon
je parle sous votre contrôle donc c'est
que le financement donc de
l'installation de ces compteurs est à la
charge des 10 qui doit se récupérer par
la suite donc ses frères à travers les
gains de productivité et qu'elle
réalisera donc ça bon reste à voir après
tout cela comment au commandement il
évoluera dans le temps c'est des raies
être bien sûr que le coup estimait
d'installation et le bon coup qui rabote
dépassement vous savez déjà vu ça dans
d'autres occasions que par exemple la
durée d'amortissement des compteurs vous
parliez d'une vingtaine d'années sera
bien soucieux sur les sur les vins
envoyé dans le dock ça ce sont certains
paramètres qui au départ on ne maîtrise
pas mais sur lesquelles on est des
gilles ans par exemple
anne-marie goussard justement donc c'est
assez un coup de combien pour aînés 10
et pas de règle pas de répercussion pour
le particulier
voilà alors le coût total est de 5
milliards pour vous expliquer votre
facture d'électricité il ya trois
parties à la partie des électrons
cerveau de consommation que vous donnez
à votre fournisseur
il ya une partie qui est liée au
transport de l'électricité sert comment
elle va de la production jusqu'à chez
vous avec deux parties une partie pour
le transport les gros câble rte
et puis une pour les petits câbles c'est
nous et puis ensuite il ya les taxes ce
tarif d'utilisation du réseau public
d'électricité il est fixé par la
commission de régulation de l'énergie
donc c'est une équation à un nombre am
acad exemple d'inconnus qui permet de le
faire ce que nous a demandé la
commission de régulation de
l'électricité c'est de faire un modèle
économique qui permet de calculer leurs
heures de calcul et le remboursement de
cet investissement c'est sûr a ajouté
que ce soit de neutre pour le client
c'est pas gratuit parce que ça fait
partie aujourd'hui vous avez un conteur
vous en aurez un demain c'est pas
gratuit
c'est neutre pour le client et dans
cette incitation il y a même une
incitation à ne pas dépasser
des coups que vous évitez que vous
évoquez les coûts de montage etc et on a
au contraire une sanction si par hasard
on déborde sur nos fiançailles donc on
est très encadré et c'est bien et c'est
normal ce qui nous oblige à la plus
grande rigueur et respecter le cahier
des charges que dans lequel nous sommes
engagés
bertrand guillon est ce que ça vous
rassure d'entendre ça déjà sur la partie
coup on verra après les sur la partie
coup s'appuyer sur les éventuels gains
de productivité à terme ça me paraît un
petit peu un petit peu compliqué ou en
tout cas pas forcément totalement fiable
à 100% donc et on a déjà vu et on voit
d'ailleurs encore en ce moment certains
coûts estimés certes sur certains
investissements tout de suite là comme
ça je pense une centrale nucléaire en ce
moment et qui en construction où les
coûts sont totalement dépassés par
rapport à ce qui était programmé au
départ et mais régné qu'une fine et le
consommer une filière de sous stations
de base c'est un consommateur qui paye
puisque c'est de toute façon dans le
cadre du consommateur puisque ses aînés
disent qu'ils payent et enée 10 cd payé
par le consommateur de toute façon alors
oui alors aux effectifs ils attendent
les transports et le transport effet que
vous dites que c'est notre ces deux
autres ça veut dire que c'est inclus
j'ai bien chez pathé j'ai pas dit
gratuit les économies elles sont sur les
absences de déplacement puisque avant se
déplacer pour faire cette activité on
les fera pas c'est sur l'optimisation
des investissements par la meilleure
connaissance du réseau donc on a un
certain nombre d'indicateurs qui sont
testés et aujourd'hui à 4 millions de
compteurs qui sont installés on en
installe en gros 20 milles par jour on
sera 35000 d'ici à la fin de l'année
donc on commence à avoir un retour
d'expérience
on a en avait en 2010 installer 300
milles compteur pour justement peaufiner
ses coûts et mieux comprendre ses coûts
et donc les 300000 compteurs posés il ya
huit ans ce qui est les 4 millions qui
sont posés depuis maintenant le débat
fin 2015 nous confirme la trajectoire
mais à nous d'être vigilants pour m et
pour que pour respecter cette
trajectoire et le contrôle de l'état là
dessus est très fort et c'est légitime
puisque c'est au bout du compte le
consommateur qui est concerné donc oui
on est très contrôlé alors j'ai engagé à
ce qu'il n'y ait pas du tout déplacement
engagés auprès de la cre eux et nous
avons des sanctions si nous ne
le respectons pas un dernier point sur
cet aspect coup fille pleurait on a
entendu des factures qui était voilà qui
était élevé après installation du
compteur linky plusieurs particuliers se
sont plaints est-ce que vous avez des
gens sont venus vous consulté pour ça
moi personnellement non mais au niveau 2
le sait que choisir en connaissance
effectivement des fêtes et que vous
évoquez généralement si lui sert d'un
dépassement en fait c'était lié à
certains problèmes techniques de deux
conteurs dont la puissance était pas et
est mal ajustée par rapport à la
consommation mais ça je pense que ça a
été réparé et réparé il manque 7 et
solutionner assez rapidement par une
addition on avait constaté effectivement
que dans certains lieux des conteurs ont
pu lire avec des docteurs qui ont pu
glisser dit on alors ce qui est prévu
par la commission de régulation de
l'énergie et qu'on met en oeuvre
c'est que si on se trouve dans une telle
situation le changement de puissance se
fait gratuitement
nous déplaçons pendant un an et qui dit
changement de puissance 10 kwh alors il
peut changer d'évoluer sion du de
l'abonnement alors sans rétroactivité
ses terres que évidemment si quelqu'un
a bénéficié pendant 10-15 auront à un
tarif inférieur on sera pas rétroactif
mais effectivement le compteur linky va
clarifier quelques situations
aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement infime par
rapport au nombre de contrats qui sont
en cours sur le camion de compteur on
est 0,00 sur les risques sanitaires
bertrand au lion vous avez peur de ces
ondes électromagnétiques d'autres
appareils comme uniques et génère aussi
ses ondes pourquoi voir cette attitude
particulière sur linkedin aujourd'hui
des recherches avancent par rapport à
l'électrosensibilité c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué ce que signaler tout à l'heure
des chercheurs au niveau international
par exemple
interroge aussi sur les normes actuelles
en signalant que ces normes sont
peut-être des niveaux trop élevés et
qu'il faudrait donc les abaisser il y a
aussi eu des engagements encore récent
sur l'utilisation de ces ondes dans
l'est dans les écoles ou ou même la
proximité de lieu pour des enfants ou
des personnes vulnérables proche de
lignes très haute tension
c'est le cas puisqu'on un sujet à magny
les hameaux avec rte là dessus sur
litres de tension qui a été installée il
ya bien longtemps et aujourd'hui il y a
une forte inquiétude de la part de la
population par rapport à à cet usage
obligé en fait un moment donné de
l'ensemble de ses outils et il y à ce
caractère obligatoire sur ce compteur
linky qui peut poser problème
aujourd'hui dans la vie d'un certain
nombre de citoyennes citoyens est là
pour nous en tant qu'élus locaux
qui représentons la population forcément
on se fait l'écho de ce de ce ressenti
de cette forte inquiétude fleuret oui
alors en ce qui concerne les risques
liés aux champs électromagnétiques nous
ce bien sûr on s'est occupé de cet
aspect là ce que l'on a constaté c'est
que tous les différents rapports des
différents organismes je pense par
exemple au rapport du conseil général de
l'environnement et du développement
durable ou rapport de l'ansés est aux
décisions de justice à ce jour il n'y a
aucun risque avéré aucun
ceci dit il faut être vigilant parce que
ce qui est la norme aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'on peut tomber sur des
seuils plus bas six bonnes c'est ce que
dit bertrand détail seuls deux ont
connaissance non ce que l'on demande par
contre c'est que les les mesures de ces
différents rapports les unités de mesure
ce soit les mêmes parce qu'on a parfois
des rapports avec des mesures
différentes et c'est de là que
représente assez difficile à oublier
donc certaine homogénéisation dans ce
domaine mais au niveau risque sanitaire
vu en l'état de nos connaissances et que
mon nom un marigot salade sujet maison
que vous avez fait beaucoup de tests
avec ces compteurs alors donc d'abord on
n'utilise pas dont on utilise le courant
porteur en ligne certains utilisent de
câbles et on a une information qui va
transiter pendant la nuit à travers ce
câble ça va durer quelques quelques
secondes les informations sont données
pendant la nuit
alors voilà serre que le compteur va
sans doute et les transmissions la vache
tokyo que le compteur va stocker votre
courbe de consommation et pendant la
nuit
elle va partir vers un concentrateur qui
se trouve dans le poste distribuer au
public le poste de quartier
et ensuite alors non elle va du compteur
jusqu'à au concentrateur elle utilise le
courant porteur en ligne
c'est quelque chose que nous on utilise
depuis soixante dix ans puisque c'est le
sait le sait ça passe par le câble c'est
par exemple ce qu'on utilise quand pour
passer de eur 2 des tarifs de nuit et
intérêts toujours au tarif de jours à
tarif de nuit c'est le courant porteur
en ligne
c'est ce que vous utilisez pour beaucoup
les baby phone qui vont du berceau de
bébés jusqu'à haut-parleurs qui est dans
le salon quand on prend la peine avec
les amis c'est le gros lot et c'est même
la même tranche dont
donc il ya le courant porteur en ligne
et puis du concentrateur et vous avez
raison
jusqu'à nos systèmes d'information c'est
le gprs le gps est ce que ces cartes sim
c'est la carte sim qu'ils ont commis
l'erreur d'un portable c'est la même
physiquement la même et pendant dix
minutes pendant la nuit il y avoir une
conversation dans le quartier
supplémentaires entre 0 et 6 heures du
matin c'est ça dont on n'entend pas
alors il n'y a pas d' onde
mais il ya effectivement comme pour tout
appareil électrique un champ
électromagnétique et aéré est là qu est
générée il est pour le compteur le
nouveau compteur comparable au compteur
précédent voire inférieures donc il n'ya
pas de sûr quand il ne télétransmettent
pas coté et quand il transmet ya 0,1
volts par mètres ce qui fait que ça
arrive au même niveau
c'est pour vous dire une ampoule ici ça
fait dix-sept fois plus je vous parle
pas de votre réfrigérateur qui fait 180
fois plus je ne veux même pas savoir
pour ce micro convient c'est donc ça
reste un film c'est entre 100 et 800
fois inférieur aux normes
maintenant ça n'empêche pas de continuer
la recherche de continuer de précaution
et surtout comme vous le dites de
favoriser l'information ça a été
soulignée par l'office parlementaire des
choix scientifiques pour qu'on ait les
mêmes protocoles les mêmes façons de
mesurer les mêmes unités de mesure de
manière à ce que chacun parle bien de la
même chose
bertrand riom comment une personne
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne souhaiteraient pas
avoir ce type de compteurs par rapport à
certains soucis de santé
puisqu'aujourd'hui il y à des évolutions
qui sont avérées quand même par rapport
à cette fameuse électrosensibilité
comment ces personnes peuvent elles se
protéger par rapport à l'ensemble de ses
usages c'est à dire que un modèle wifi
etc ou même des interrupteurs
électriques qui qui qui peuvent produire
un certain nombre de problématiques
on peut les choisir on peut on peut
enlever certains éléments demandés droit
au choix rouge aujourd'hui le compteur
linky on ne peut pas le choisir
le législateur a prévu effectivement n'a
pas prévu plutôt qu' il puisse y avoir
des exceptions à la loi
d'autant plus que le changement du
compteur est prévue dans les contrats
que vous avez avec vos fournisseurs
cirque il est prévu que l'on puisse
intervenir à n'importe quel moment sur
ce compteur nous ce qu'on peut dire en
tant qu'électricien on peut pas
intervenir dans des bas non politique
mais sociétal sociologique c'est que ce
conteur né mais pas plus que le
précédent
ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il ne vient
pas rajouter une couche à l'ensemble du
bruit est ce qu'on appelle le brouillard
électromagnétique
quand vous êtes dans une pièce normal
dans un appartement normal où il ya un
réfrigérateur une lampe 3.5 voile par m
quand vous êtes à 20 cm du conteur ya
moins d'un volt par mètre c'est à dire
que cette inférieur au brouillard merci
marie nous a fait pleurer là dessus est
ce que vous pourriez envisager de faire
évoluer les choses si des personnes
voilà électrosensibles seul
moi je vais me rapporter au rapport du
conseil général un kiki preque et donc
nous partageons les conclusions qui
préconise que pour les installations
atypique par exemple des pièces très
exigu où des personnes qui seraient qui
serait chez elle très longtemps et qui
donc créé un contact avec les
installations dans des périodes longues
que les recherches continuent dans ce
domaine pour faire avancer les résultats
un dernier point sur les données
personnelles alors bertrand ouvre là
dessus une inquiétude où vont ces
données c'est la question aujourd'hui
alors je fais référence à des
informations qu'on a pu voir sur sur les
reportages à la télé notamment et où on
remarque qu'il y a une possibilité de
par rapport aux montées de charge la
possibilité de savoir très précisément
ce qu'on fait quand et quel est le mode
de consommation de l'électricité quel
est le mode de vie finalement de chacune
des personnes et est là dessus il y as
forcément possibilité d'utiliser un
moment donné ces données il y à une
protection des données qui qui existent
en france je sais qu est ce que je peux
choisir justement est intervenu dans ce
domaine pour pouvoir en limiter
l'utilisation donc aujourd'hui à priori
les compteurs sont bloqués en tout cas
le pour éviter l'utilisation de de ce
type de données à moins de dix minutes
mais
on peut toujours débloquer quelque chose
quand même
et aujourd'hui lusage marketing qui peut
être fait des données personnelles est
quelque chose qui inquiète encore une
fois les usages et les consommateurs on
le voit dans d'autres domaines
bastien est aujourd'hui le voir aussi
dans le domaine de l'électricité par et
on peut sans risque pour vous
administrez philippe le ray un mot
là-dessus position donc effectivement
dès 2012 on a alerté les pouvoirs
publics sur ce sujet donc à partir des
travaux de la cnil
il est désormais donc techniquement
décidé que les remontées ne seront pas
en dessous des périodes inférieures à 10
minutes et c'est à dire dix minutes donc
ne permettent pas ces conditions d'avoir
une connaissance fine des comportements
et des habitudes déjà une assurance de
ce côté là je crois aussi qu'il ya des
possibilités aussi on peut demander les
particuliers peuvent demander si klaus
moteur est débranché déconnecté je crois
de préciser voilà et puis ça a pas
trente après lui faudra aussi vigilance
et pour d autres sociétés qui
proposerait des logiciels pour des
suivis de consommation ou des courbes de
consommation
ça c'est pas encore
[Musique]
de ce côté là alain goût ça rapidement
la mer en face aux complexités le client
qui le propriétaire de ses données et en
aucun cas nous ne pouvons les
communiquer à qui que ce soit sans une
autorisation explicite
deuxièmement les données que nous avons
sont des données globales et il n'y a
aucune donnée par usage d'abord parce
qu'on n'a aucun moyen de les avoir et
ensuite ça n'a aucun intérêt pour nous
on est un entrepôt de service public
l'objectif d'un compteur sept comtés
pour pouvoir faire une facture c'est la
vraie vie donc
et effectivement il ya des tas
d'appareils de domotique et c'est qu'on
peut avoir avec ou sans lits qui sert
qu'on peut avoir une énergie box qui
vous dit combien kung fu sommes votre
aspirateur sans linky et on peut avoir
les glissant énergybox donc ces deux
choses qui sont fondamentalement
dissocier et puis la courbe de charge
aujourd'hui nous ne lâcherons pas nous
ne la sto coup que si vous le demandez
c'est à dire que c'est par défaut elle
n'est pas stocké ce n est qu elle ait
donné son nom n'a que la donnée globale
sermonnait leur consommation de la
journée on n'a pas votre de consommation
des dix minutes et on ne l'a on a que la
consommation globale pardonner par
défaut si vous nous demandez une corde
de charges nous allons enclencher la
courbe de charge pour pouvoir vous la
restituer que vous puissiez suivre votre
consommation mais par défaut nous
n'allons pas donc c'est un choix du
consommateur et ça n'est pas un choix
des néo 10 passons en conclusion
bertrand ou lyon qu'est-ce que vous
attendez qu est-ce qui
rassurerait tout ça vraiment qui est
jeanne ring déjà une raison visiblement
une force est forcément dans mes
inspirations toutes ces questions là
c'est des questions qui nous sont posées
à nous en tant qu'élu on n'a pas de
réponse
derrière on intervient et
c'est logique c'est notre rôle on serait
fautif de ne pas prendre ces
délibérations
une fois que nous sommes alertés par les
habitants par rapport à des
problématiques qui qui dépasse le le
cadre simple de l'aménagement de notre
territoire mais qui influe directement
sur le mode de vie et la possibilité de
vivre tranquillement chez soi pour pour
les habitants de notre commune et pour
les habitants de l'ensemble des communes
sans information précise et sans
information
disons qu'ils ne peut souffrir d'aucun
doute aussi de la part des nez dit c'est
peut-être de bureau de contrôle
extérieur et indépendant
ça paraît compliqué d'accepter ce type
de ce type d'équipement même si au delà
de ça on est tous très volontaire par
rapport à b toutes les possibilités qui
nous permettent de suivre au mieux nos
consommations personnelles et surtout
d'économiser de l'énergie
maintenant aujourd'hui nous on a reçus
j'ai reçu en tant que maire dé des
recours gracieux de la part notamment
des 10 est ce que je demande tout
simplement avec des 10 et déjà de
remettre à plus tard ce recours le temps
de mettre en place une réunion publique
de pouvoir discuter et qu'ensuite on
puisse voir les suites qui seront
données le tout sans qu'on finit fleuret
très rapidement votre conclusion on aura
de plus en plus rapidement équipements
demandant c'est que les bénéfices du
déploiement de ces compteurs linky ne se
fasse pas essentiellement au profit des
10 mai qu'il se soit plus partager les
gains de soi plus partagée pour profit
des consommateurs de la transparence et
de la pédagogique d'expliquer exactement
toutes les possibilités et tous les
avantages de ces contes oraux ce matin
alain gosselin a scanné 10 est en mesure
de promettre toutes ces garanties
alors notre rôle c'est d'expliquer et
donc on est là pour informer aujourd'hui
et on continue à l'être partout sur le
territoire
donc je pense que ça c'est que c'est
vous avez raison c'est essentiel de
pouvoir répondre aux questions des
consommateurs et surtout de faire
comprendre que c'est des qui est l'outil
de la transition énergétique et qu'on ne
peut pas à la fois vouloir le
développement des énergies renouvelables
des nouveaux usages des rats et ne pas
vouloir gêner qui il faudra qu'on ait un
outil pour gérer cette transition
énergétique et c'est ce qu'on veut
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à cette émission on se retrouve mardi
prochain pour un nouveau débat merci à
votre abattoirs
[Musique]